Dans « Pourquoi On Dit ? »,
je vous raconte cequi se cache derrière
les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous
et n'oubliez pas...
que je suis cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Connaissez-vous l'origine du mot « vaccin » ?
Au départ,
il y a une maladie :
la variole.
Au XVIIIème siècle,
elle fait des ravages.
Des dizaines de milliers de morts en Europe.
Selon certainschiffres,
quand une épidémie se déclarait,
elle pouvait toucher
60 % de la population
et emporter
presque un quart des malades.
Cette maladie
se manifeste par l'apparition de pustules sur lapeau,
d'où son nom :
« variola »
qui veut dire « bouton » en latin.
A l'époque,
on remarque que certainespopulations
sont moins touchées que les autres.
C'est le cas des femmes qui travaillent
àla ferme
et qui sont chargées de la traite des vaches.
Autre observation intéressante,
les bovins,
dont elles s'occupent,
sont quant à eux affectés par une forme
moins virulente de la variole.
Unemaladie baptisée :
« vaccine »,
du latin « vacca »
qui veut dire « vache ».
En 1796
un médecin de campagneanglais,
Edward Jenner,
a une intuition.
Et si la vaccine des vaches
protégeait les fermières dela variole ?
Il a alors l'idée d'inoculer cette vaccine
à un être humain,
pour le protéger de lavariole.
C'est risqué
mais tant pis
il se lance !
Jenner
griffe le bras d'un jeune garçon,
JamesPhipps,
et l'infecte avec le virus de la vaccine.
Dans les jours qui suivent,
l'enfant est chaud,
la fièvre monte.
Mais au bout du compte,
il s'en remet.
Quelques temps après,
Jenner décide d'infecter son jeune patient
avec la variole cette fois.
L'angoisse monte
mais pour rien
car James ne tombe pas malade !
Jenner
vient de mettre au point ce que l'on va appeler:
le vaccin
et la vaccination.
Une technique
qui permet de protéger
contre des formes sévèresd'une maladie
en inoculant un virus atténué
dans le corps des patients.
L'organisme développe alorsdes défenses immunitaires
qui passent à l'attaque
quand un virus
en bonne et due forme se présente.
Le vaccin contre la variole
a depuis été utilisé dans le monde entier.
L'OMS a même déclaréla variole :
première maladie officiellement éradiquée de la planète,
en 1980
grâce à lavaccination.
C'est vachement bien, non ?